le quartier est ce qu'on appelle un
désert médical
on a le temps de crever avant de pouvoir
avoir un rendez-vous de visa sur
hochelaga maisonneuve manque cruellement
de docteur plus de 30% de la population
n'a pas de médecin de famille le des
pires résultats au québec
j'en cherche un faible total ont même
conseillé à la ligne téléphonique de
continuer mes recherches personnelles
parce que c'était deux ans et demi
d'attendre mais voilà aux fins des ro
forts comme la docteur christine wallet
28 ans ça fait juste deux semaines j'ai
commencé mais je vois aussi beaucoup
d'isolement social donc des gens avec
peu de ressources
et oui certainement des problèmes de
santé mentale elle fait partie d'un
groupe de 14 médecins qui a décidé de
venir pratiquer dans ce quartier
défavorisé
c'est un premier temps six médecins
l'année prochaine donc c'est vraiment un
mouvement concret qui va amener une
masse critique de médecins ça pourrait
permettre à dix mille patients orphelins
d'hochelaga maisonneuve de finalement se
trouver un médecin de famille tu vas
aller au quai et soulager les médecins
comme julie bélanger qui tiennent fort
ici depuis quatre ans je me retrouvais
un peu mal prise pour vous on va vous
référer à quelques pas mais il y en a
pas de quelque part vous vous référez
puis les besoins sont criants
les 14 nouveaux médecins seront bientôt
regroupés dans une clinique où ils
seront appuyés par des infirmières et
des travailleurs sociaux
mais la docteure bélanger pense qu'il
faudra encore aller plus loin les
chiffres nous disent qu'ils manquent 79
points dans la région de l'est de
montréal donc ne comprenait que 7 14
extraordinaire mais ça nous en prend
encore plus vous pouvez rentrer ici vous
asseoir leur reste que l'arrivée de
médecins comme christine wallet donne
déjà des résultats
ceux souffrant place natasha st louis
qui vit dans l'est de montréal est ravi
de trouver un médecin après une très
longue attente depuis 2015 que j'étais
sur la liste